j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public avec quatre sénatrices et
sénateurs des principaux groupes
représentés à la Chambre haute ma
première question portera sur le rôle de
contre-pouvoir du Sénat contre-pouvoir
indispensable à digérateur Larcher hier
comment va-t-il s'exercer dans les
prochaines semaines notamment sur la loi
immigration ou sur l'examen du budget
première réponse avec Fabien avec Air la
droite perd quelques sièges mais reste
la force dominante au Sénat pas de
révolution donc au Palais du Luxembourg
mais de la stabilité Gérard Larcher s'en
est félicité après le scrutin le Sénat
continuera à être ce contre-pouvoir
indispensable à la démocratie face à un
exécutif privé de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale la droite
sénatoriale est en position de force
dans le jeu parlementaire par exemple
sur le projet de loi immigration très
attendu le texte doit être examiné en
novembre au Sénat entre elle et
l'exécutif une ligne rouge la
régularisation des sans-papiers qui
travaillent dans les métiers en tension
comme lors de l'examen de la réforme des
retraites adopté au Sénat grâce aux
voies de LR le gouvernement ne pourra
pas faire sans la droite sénatoriale la
majorité est relative et qui plus est
fracturée et donc elle n'a pas intérêt à
ce que le Sénat joue les troubles fêtes
si jamais le gouvernement veut avoir le
soutien au moins tacite d'une partie de
la droite sénatoriale et ben il doit la
considérer il doit l'écouter autre temps
fort de l'automne l'examen du budget
avec une bataille d'amendements et de
49-3 en perspective à l'Assemblée le
gouvernement aura de nouveau besoin du
Sénat et donc des voies LR pour faire
adopter son texte par un vote même si le
patron des sénateurs en marche préfèrent
relativiser le poids de la droite nous
avons fait une majorité avec elle sur
les retraites mais nous avons fait une
majorité avec la gauche
sur le réchauffement climatique sur le
développement durable et sur l'économie
verte cela vous fait donc demain nous
continuerons à rechercher ces majorités
alternatives avec ceux qui aujourd'hui
pensent que après tout l'intérêt général
dépasse l'intérêt partisan après le
projet de loi de finances viendra
l'examen du budget de la Sécurité
sociale sur lequel le Sénat a déjà rendu
un rapport alarmant cet été
anthroposition et majorité de
circonstances le pas de 2 entraîne l'air
et le gouvernement devrait se poursuivre
au lendemain des sénatoriales et je vous
présente tout de suite les invités de
notre débat Dominique Estrosi ça sonne
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous êtes
c'est natrice CLR des Alpes-Maritimes
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie bonsoir
bienvenue c'est la triste socialiste de
Paris Claude malurey bonsoir et
bienvenue c'est la sœur de l'Allier
président du groupe Les Indépendants ici
au Sénat Yann Brossard bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue au Sénat doublement plus merci
d'être élu sénateur comme une liste de
Paris Dominique et sauce je commence
avec vous après des soirées de défaites
électorales présidentielles législatives
vous allez retrouver le sourire hier
soir il faut garder parce que ce sont
des élections sénatoriales qui prennent
en compte un ancrage territorial de bons
résultats que nous avions obtenu aux
élections municipales de 2020 de la à
dire que effectivement c'est un long
fleuve tranquille maintenant par rapport
aux élections qui s'annoncent ne gomme
pas toutes les difficultés
précédents puis voilà il faut voir aussi
que dans le groupe les républicains on a
vraiment des membres qui
occupent des convictions et très très
larges et qui ne sont pas forcément
toutes sur la même ligne que notre
famille politique mais pour autant
revendique bien sûr d'appartenir à notre
famille politique des républicains et on
a aussi un président de groupe qui
arrive à rassembler en son sein est-ce
que le Sénat est un havre de paix pour
les parties historiques
je vois pas très bien le sens de votre
question pour tout vous dire et je
pensais que vous aviez posé la même
question c'est un peu la même question
formuler différemment non simplement je
crois que alors je vais le Parti social
aux dernières élections
la même réponse que que ma collègue
exposé ça sonne c'est que effectivement
nous sommes représentants de deux
parties qui sont très implantées dans
les collectivités locales donc la
représentation au Sénat en est la
traduction alors havre de paix je ne
sais pas en tout cas on est un groupe
assez nombreux on est 64 je ne sais pas
exactement combien nous serons demain
mais tout ça bon les élections se sont
bien passées par ailleurs moi j'ai été
réélu à Paris avec Yann Brossat on a
fait un très beau score on peut se le
dire puisqu'on est entre nous on a huit
sièges sur 12 donc on a progressé donc à
votre paix mais dynamique donc oui non
c'est intéressant pour la gauche Claude
malurey le scrutin d'hier soir est-ce
que c'est un succès pour Édouard
Philippe
si on le juge par le nombre de sénateurs
qui n'est pas complètement thermique pas
comme le nom connu à l'heure qu'il est
mais si on ne juge par le nom de
sénateurs annoncé aujourd'hui
actuellement
c'est un succès c'est le nombre de sa
nature du groupe des indépendants va
augmenter de environ 30% et tout le
monde revendique sa victoire évidemment
dans les lendemains d'élection c'est
clair
Renaissance parce que c'était un
objectif de la soirée plusieurs groupes
plusieurs groupes du Sénat Renaissance
RDSE et que l'eau sont à peu près au
même niveau il est possible qu'on soit
devant ses autres groupes mais c'est
aujourd'hui difficile de lire quoi qu'il
en soit on pose la question est-ce que
c'était un objectif de la soirée dans
l'objectif de la soirée c'était plus
d'implantations vous connaissez
l'objectif d'Édouard Philippe c'est
d'implanter son mouvement horizon dans
l'ensemble des territoires et
essentiellement basés sur les communes
alors évidemment quand on a une
stratégie qui consiste à aller
s'implanter dans les communes au moment
des Sénator c'est évidemment le bon
moment si je peux dire et la preuve on
est là mais le groupe des indépendance
est pas seulement le le parti d'Édouard
Philippe c'est horizon plus des membres
d'autres parties plus des indépendants
entièrement indépendants qui n'ont pas
de carte de parti de ce point de vue là
et du point de vue donc on revient à la
stratégie d'Édouard Philippe je pense
que au moment où les parties sont pas
particulièrement à la mode le pari de
créer un nouveau parti et de le créer à
partir de l'implantation dans les
territoires c'était à Paris pas évident
c'était un pari audacieux il est pas
gagné pour autant mais si on en juge pas
aujourd'hui le nombre d'adhérents de
militants et le nombre des sénateurs et
le nombre des députés c'est un pari qui
est en bonne voie d'être rempli alors on
va parler du Parti communiste évidemment
avec vous tout de suite Yann Brossat
mais d'abord un une réaction à propos de
la circonscription des Hauts-de-Seine la
gauche espérait avoir deux sièges et on
aura finalement un seul celui de Pierre
ouzouglias la faute à la France
insoumise selon écoute
beaucoup de tristesse beaucoup de
tristesse on a fait un énorme travail de
rassemblement de toutes les forces de la
gauche et la liste dissidence de la
France insoumise nous fait perdre le
second siège et fait perdre toute la
gauche je comprends pas comment à partir
d'instructions politicienne nationale on
peut casser des dynamiques locales je
suis vraiment très amer c'est un siège
qui nous échappe à trois voies la France
insoumise emporte la totale
responsabilité Yann bossa au-delà des
Hauts-de-Seine est-ce que vous en voulez
vous aussi aux candidats de la France
insoumise il y a quelques cas comme ceux
évoqués par Pierre ouzulias à l'instant
mais tout ça n'a pas empêché la gauche
de progresser globalement lors de ces
élections sénatoriales c'est le cas pour
l'ensemble des composantes de la gauche
c'est le cas notamment pour les
communistes puisque nous gagnons entre
deux et trois sièges je note d'ailleurs
que c'est le deuxième renouvellement
consécutif qui voit le groupe communiste
progressé en effectif donc pour nous
c'est une c'est une bonne soirée
le communiqué de LFI hier soir le refus
de l'Union autour de la nupesse aura
coûté à la gauche près de 10 sièges
ouais je je ne sais vraiment pas d'où
sort ce calcul et puis avec des si on
peut on peut mettre Paris en bouteille
non ce que je vois moi c'est que la
gauche progresse et dans un moment où
tant de Français ont des difficultés de
pouvoir d'achat ou la question du
travail de l'inflation est au cœur des
préoccupations des gens avoir une gauche
combative avec un groupe communiste
renforcé c'est une bonne nouvelle
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie depuis des
semaines voire des mois la nupesse alors
peut-être que c'est médiatiquement mais
bon voilà la nups ne produit que de la
division
est-ce que cet alliance a encore un
avenir ben écoutez moi j'ai souvent
l'occasion de dire que la nuit Pesse a
été une stratégie électorale au moment
des législatives qui étaient d'ailleurs
sans doute nécessaire quoi qu'on pense
les uns les autres y compris moi ça n'a
pas grand intérêt et qui a permis
effectivement cette alliance avec un
coût humain en tout cas très lourd
pour autant est-ce que ça peut perdurer
peut-être ça dépend beaucoup de l'état
d'esprit de chacune des formations
politiques et c'est vrai que parfois il
est quand même difficile de considérer
qu'avec la personnalité de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est extrêmement clivante
et qui est parfois insultante mais je
laisserai d'autres l'évoquer avec les
propos sur Fabien Roussel voilà on n'est
pas quand même c'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille alors pour autant à gauche on
a la tradition depuis toujours du
rassemblement de l'union de la gauche
etc historiquement en tout cas dans
l'histoire contemporaine donc rechercher
toujours la possibilité d'une union de
la gauche évidemment
sauf que là c'est le spectacle inverse
qui est donné c'est pas totalement le
spectacle inverse alors je voudrais pas
donner l'impression de parler que de
Paris quoi que ça fait forcément plaisir
c'est que nous l'avons fait à Paris nous
avons fait une liste d'union à Paris et
ça a permis de remporter 8 sièges
chevaux
national évidemment je vous réponds les
illustrations non mais ça a pu se faire
dans d'autres endroits mais la française
soumise dans une autre stratégie
effectivement de déposer des listes
partout elle a fait également à Paris
mais elle l'a fait partout avec une
volonté quand même de
on a un problème stratégique
effectivement avec eux ça ne produit pas
que des divisions mais je pense la
responsabilité pèse sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de savoir ce qu'il veut
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'il veut que tous
les déformations politiques membres de
la nups j'en termine sa ligne et donc
effectivement ça sera difficile parce
que ce n'est pas notre culture est-ce
qu'on peut être dans un partenariat
intelligent et respectueux ça peut être
challenge pour lui visiblement mais dans
ce cas là la nuit pêche peut prospérer
elle est parmi les élus qui font leur
entrée au Sénat et à l'ancien candidat
europécologie l'hiver à la
présidentielle Yannick Jadot on écoute
dans ce quinquennat Macron
particulièrement étrange du point de vue
des fonctionnements des deux assemblées
vous voyez que le Sénat tient sa place
s'il y avait pas eu les écologistes au
Sénat pour porter la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG il y
aurait pas eu le débat dans notre pays
pour savoir si enfin le président de la
République allaité cette introduction
dans la Constitution c'est pas eu les
écologistes pour contribuer aux
commissions d'enquête ou au débat sur
les énergies renouvelables comme vous
allez voir le débat sur l'immigration et
bien cette assemblée serait simplement
une assemblée de droite conservatrice et
peut-être un peu poussiéreuse et ben on
est là pour dépoussiérer est-ce que
c'est n'a besoin d'être dépoussiéré
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne non je pense
que c'est très exagéré aujourd'hui on
vient on voit bien que le Sénat est
inscrit dans une dynamique que le Sénat
c'est beaucoup au cours de ces dernières
années féminisées et c'est beaucoup
rajeuni et puis tu le sais encore un
écart avec l'Assemblée nationale quand
même une petite dizaine d'années pas
très important quand même avec deux
modes de scrutin qui ne sont pas les
mêmes donc quand vous êtes au scrutin
proportionnel vous n'avez pas les mêmes
choses que en scrutin majoritaire et
puis je pense aussi que le Sénat a
montré aujourd'hui combien il était
sérieux dans son travail combien il
avait un esprit d'indépendance en esprit
de responsabilité et je crois que ça ça
a marqué tant le public qui considérait
effectivement le Sénat peut-être même
parfois mais on n'entend plus du tout
comme étant
inutile et surtout aussi les grands
électeurs je crois que les grands
électeurs aussi sont des gens qui sont
responsables et qui voient le travail
qui est fait au Sénat d'ailleurs sur
tous les bancs de l'hémicycle c'est vrai
que Claude malurec l'image du Sénat dans
l'opinion elle a elle a changé assez
radicalement depuis 10 mois oui elle a
changé elle s'est améliorée au fur et
pardon et puis l'affaire Benalla oui je
dirais pour monter plus loin on peut
remonter plus là mais là il y a
l'équilibre politique lié à l'absence de
majorité pour pour
les élections législatives c'est assez
simple l'image
considérablement pour la déplacer et en
proportion de la dégradation de l'image
de l'Assemblée nationale
a été transformé notamment
essentiellement par les filles en ZAD en
zone indéliré et plus les plus les
Français voient ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale à la télévision
moi je veux dire chaque fois que je
rentre dans mon département dans
l'Allier le week-end j'entends des gens
qui me disent quand je vois ça à la
télévision des gens qui sont pas des des
révolutionnaires ou quoi des gens qui
ont voté toute leur vie et qui me disent
je ne vais plus aller voter il y a un
discrédit essentiellement de LFI
aujourd'hui mais qui entraîne un
discrédit de l'Assemblée nationale et
par ricochet évidemment une une
amélioration de l'image du Sénat mais ce
que disait Dominique gastrosi ça sonné
est vrai cette amélioration elle est
aussi le fait que le Sénat fonctionne
bien que son président est un opposant
au gouvernement mais que c'est un
opposant qui dialogue qui discute et ou
par conséquent les lois peuvent être
discutées n'ont pas dans l'affrontement
n'ont pas dans le délire mais dans dans
la discussion le gouvernement je suis
sûr n'est pas extrêmement satisfait des
lois qui sortent du Sénat parce qu'elles
ont été largement modifiées par rapport
au texte initial mais en général ce
qu'on peut voir c'est quand elle sorte
il y a une loi elle est proposée et il
n'y a pas de 49-3 d'ailleurs bien
entendu il y a pas de 49 trous au Sénat
et on arrive quand même ce qui est une
bonne chose je pense Ian brossa vous
préparez à travailler beaucoup ça bosse
ici j'ai pas prévu de de me tourner les
pouces et dans les mandats que j'ai
exercé par le passé ce d'adjoint la mère
de Paris en charge du logement depuis
maintenant une dizaine d'années j'ai pas
le sentiment d'avoir chaud mais c'était
un peu volontairement un peu provocateur
je ne vous avais pourquoi vous avez
choisi le Sénat
entre guillemets à participer de votre
choix mais parce que comme beaucoup je
crois de nos concitoyens je suis un peu
lassé par une politique qui vit
uniquement au rythme des polémiques j'y
ai par ailleurs parfois participé mais
je pense qu'on a besoin d'autre chose
on a besoin de construire qu'on a besoin
de travailler alors ici bien sûr le
groupe communiste il est dans
l'opposition mais j'ai envie qu'on
incarne et je crois que ça a été le cas
au cours des années passées une
opposition qui bien sûr ferme qui est
bien sûr résolu mais qui n'est pas
outrancière et je pense qu'on a on a
vraiment besoin de ça et dans un climat
qui est quand même très anxiogène où les
gens beaucoup de difficultés ils
n'attend pas il n'attendent pas de leur
responsable politique qu'il jette de lui
sur le feu ils ont plutôt envie de gens
qui se battent pour trouver des
solutions on va parler de la majorité
présidentielle le groupe Renaissance qui
perd alors on n'est pas d'accord avec
François Patriat sur le décompte lui dit
on est à 20 21 nous on en est on est
plutôt à 17 bref on verra bien dans les
prochains jours qui a qui a raison en
tout cas pour Bruno Retailleau le chef
de fil des sénateurs LR les républicains
il y a une explication à cette défaite
du parti Renaissance voilà ce qui nous
dit
jamais il y a eu autant découragement
les mers sont épuisées ils sont épuisés
parce que il y a Paris puis il y a les
territoires ils ont le sentiment que
tout est gouverné de Paris que en
réalité rien n'est résolu au niveau
national et qu'en plus le niveau
national ajoute et sur Ajouter de plus
en plus de normes de contraintes Paris
gouverne par la norme et l'État
n'accompagne plus vraiment les
collectivités je pense que c'est cette
déconnexion en réalité qui est à
l'origine du revers du parti
présidentiel
ça doit pas vous arriver souvent est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec Bono
Retailleau en tout cas il faut voir ma
chrononise déconnecter du réel tu verras
c'est quelque chose qui peut arriver
en tout cas je suis convaincu qu'il faut
donner en particulier aux collectivités
locales davantage de de moyens de faire
je vais frapper par le fait que comme
élu en charge du logement à Paris
régulièrement j'ai été confronté au fait
que des dispositions qui paraissent
évidentes ne pouvaient pas être mise en
œuvre parce qu'on attendait un
changement législatif et parce que
l'État mettait deux ans à publier un
décret par exemple j'ai vu dans la
régulation d'Airbnb et des locations
touristiques et donc ça me donne envie
effectivement de donner plus de moyens
aux collectivités d'agir dans l'intérêt
des populations qui vivent sur leur
territoire hier soir 20h TF1 France 2
Emmanuel Macron en direct Claude maillot
est-ce que c'est une mauvaise manière
faite au sénatrice et sénateur quand
même je crois qu'il faut pas c'est un
peu éclipser dans les matinales les
résultats de de la des sénatoriales
c'était fait pour
peut-être vous savez s'il l'avait fait
la veille c'était on aurait dit que
c'était le la Coupe du monde de rugby
s'il l'avait fait trois jours avant
c'était une autre séance je pense qu'il
faut arrêter les procès en machiavélisme
choisir de faire une grosse intervention
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas quelqu'un qui
s'exprime souvent en interview à la
télévision faire une grosse intervention
programmée sans raison
identifier un attentat que sais-je ce
soir-là par ailleurs pu dit le soir de
Kippour j'ai trouvé que c'était assez
étrange tout de même mais bon c'est
comme ça on sait qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
s'intéresse pas à ce qu'il appelle les
corps intermédiaires nous en faisons
partie visiblement et par ailleurs vu le
résultat des élections pour son parti
ceci explique peut-être cela
je pense qu'il pouvait pas prévoir à
l'avance personne pouvait prévoir avant
ce résultat ces élections deuxièmement
la région des élections
c'est des élections de mi-mandat faut
pas non plus sur interpréter vous disiez
tout le monde est à bout le situation
sociale etc c'est pas d'aujourd'hui non
plus ça frappe tous les gouvernements le
PS l'a connu le LR les républicains ont
connu quand vous êtes au gouvernement
les élections de mimanda sont des
élections qui se passent pas pas bien en
général ce qu'il faut relativiser parce
que dans cette dans la majorité si
Renaissance a été une mauvaise tête
d'affiche et je peux dire le reste de
majorité horizon et le modem ont fait
des bons résultats donc si on si on met
tout dans la balance c'est pratiquement
une stabilité au niveau de la majorité
présidentielle donc voilà maintenant les
les
comment dire le choix de la le choix de
la date peut-être effectivement que le
Président de la République c'est sa
responsabilité
souhaite parler d'autre chose que du
résultat mais ce résultat tu vas
particulièrement catastrophique moi je
dis je dis mauvaise manière je pense que
c'est ce que je ressens Dominique et ça
sonne un mot là-dessus faire diversion
et il a vraiment parlé d'autres choses
il a parlé tellement d'autres choses que
on ne sait pas mieux de quoi il a parlé
dans les sujets ont été on va y revenir
dans un instant il y a eu des
déclarations sur l'immigration sur des
pompes à chaleur puis après quand on
parle du Niger enfin excusez-moi c'est
un peu c'est un peu le le lot d'une
intervention présidentielle où on balaye
les deux jours un public a parlé du prix
de l'essence est-ce que c'est de voilà
donc on peut quand même s'interroger et
force de constater que bien évidemment
il a voulu enjamber les résultats des
élections sénatoriales allez on va se
projeter sur le calendrier des des
prochains jours des prochaines semaines
grâce à Quentin calmé qui peut nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau rebonsoir
Quentin bienvenue à vous allez des infos
précises sur la suite du calendrier ici
au Sénat et bien les prochains jours
sont importants effectivement Thomas
déjà aussi pour comprendre la
composition politique exacte de
l'hémicycle parce que vous le disiez
depuis le début définition on a encore
des on tâtonne encore
on ne sait pas exactement dans quel
groupe politique ils vont siéger ils
sont pour l'instant rangés dans ce
groupe divers droits ou divers centre on
verra maintenant où est-ce qu'exactement
ils vont aller se positionner ça ça va
se jouer notamment demain le 26
septembre on va y avoir plus clair aussi
parce que ce sera l'élection des
présidents des groupes politiques chaque
camp choisi une personnalité pour les
représenter et en ce moment d'ailleurs
des tractations sont en cours pour
courtiser les sénateurs qui n'ont pas
encore choisi leur groupe politique la
liste finale des groupes politiques sera
arrêté le 3 octobre on verra aussi
particulièrement et bien ce qui se passe
au groupe socialiste le sortant Patrick
Kanner devrait voir
Eric kerrouj sénateur réélu dans les
Landes ah oui il y a une inversion des
noms voilà
réussir à inverser les noms toutes nos
excuses voilà mais à maxima
culparé est à gauche Éric CAO est à
droite et donc en la ligne politique du
groupe sur fond de désaccord sur
l'alliance avec la Nupe oui évidemment
on en reparlera autre événement
important l'élection du président du
Sénat et là je pense pas qu'on va se
tromper d'infographie
les deux octobre et effectivement en
fait c'est le premier sujet alors
l'ordre du jour de la reprise des
travaux de la séance c'est une séance
effectivement le 2 octobre et qui va
être spécial au Sénat pour l'occasion
elle sera présidée par le sénateur doyen
d'âge en l'occurrence Jean-Marie
vandlerenberg c'était déjà lui en 2020
qui avait présidé cette séance
particulière il pourra même prononcer un
discours à ce moment-là on verra aussi
le benjamin en l'occurrence la benjamine
du Sénat il y a trois ans c'était le
socialiste Rémi Cardon et cette fois-ci
ce sera l'écologie c'était mettre l'île
d'Olivier 29 ans qui a fait son entrée
au Sénat hier et qui va donc tenir
l'urne du vote cette élection elle sera
à suivre en direct et en intégralité
c'est donc le octobre lundi prochain et
un mot aussi Thomas que je voulais
mentionner c'est la répartition des
commissions permanentes le 4 octobre on
verra aussi qu'il va y avoir pas mal de
bouger dans les présidents de ces
commissions certains nouveaux sénateurs
vont faire l'entrée dans les commissions
on va voir aussi des changements à la
tête de ces commissions et donc ce 10
octobre voilà c'est la dernière date que
je voulais évoquer c'est la reprise
formelle des travaux parlementaires on
verra qu'elles sont les premiers textes
inscrits à l'ordre du jour mais très
rapidement des textes importants vont
arriver notamment les textes budgétaires
qui sont examinés c'est la coutume à
l'automne au Parlement et c'est à suivre
bien sûr sur Public Sénat merci beaucoup
Quentin pour les prochaines semaines
Gérard Larcher d'ailleurs annonce la
couleur déclaration hier soir le Sénat
continuera à être ce contre-pouvoir
indispensable à la démocratie
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie je reviens
vers vous on va ouvrir un chapitre
immigration dans ce débat est-ce que
vous craignez que le Sénat soit
finalement un allié du gouvernement sur
cette question précise de l'immigration
en tout cas la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat ecoutez on a eu
l'occasion ce texte a déjà été examiné
en commission des lois au mois de mars
et puis son chemin parlementaire a été
interrompu et on a vu à ce moment-là que
la majorité de droite donc du Sénat
l'avait durci à nouveau et fait assez
peu fréquent me semble-t-il même si je
n'ai pas une expérience très longue ici
sur le l'article qui organise le système
de la régularisation des sans-papiers
dans les métiers en tension la
Commission n'a pas pris position car il
y avait un désaccord entre les
rapporteurs et donc à renvoyer ce débat
la séance pourquoi est-ce que je
développe ça c'est que sur je pense que
ce texte pour ma part je pense qu'il ne
sera jamais voté et que il n'y aura
jamais de loi immigration issue de ce
texte pourquoi ce texte est composé de
deux blocs un bloc qui traite
globalement des questions du séjour et
de manière
comment dire précise la question de la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension ce bloc pourrait je
dis bien pourrait parce que tout n'est
pas bon en tout cas avoir l'oreille
intéressé de la part de la gauche d'une
partie de la majorité présidentielle
voire d'une partie décentriste qui se
sont exprimés sur ces sujets-là l'autre
bloc mais pas de la droite et de LR je
résume je m'en excuse pour les collègues
mais j'essaye de faire simple l'autre
bloc mais c'est le même projet de loi
est un bloc très répressif sur les
modalités de recours d'admission de
reconduction etc sur lequel la gauche ne
pourra pas donner son accord tel qu'il
est a forti avec les durcissements qui
ont été introduits par la Commission de
cohérence globale
c'est que moi je ne sais pas comment un
texte peut être voté une partie
peut-être par la gauche une autre partie
peut-être par la droite mais ça ça ne
fait pas un texte voté et je pense que
ce sera sans doute assez semblable à
l'Assemblée donc donc j'ai bien compris
que la première ministre avait mis la
pression sur le ministre de l'Intérieur
qui est prié régulièrement de retourner
à ses travaux de trouver un compromis de
tenter de le trouver avec LR mais au
bout du bout parfois parce que j'ai
l'esprit un peu mal tourné je me demande
si la première ministre n'essaye pas de
voilà de mettre Gérald Darmanin au pied
du mur pour montrer qu'il est choue mais
ça c'est autre chose donc donc je pense
qu'effectivement il y a une tentation
parce qu'il faut bien trouver une
solution pour le gouvernement de
travailler avec LR mais dans ce cas en
faisant l'impasse sur les sur la
régularisation des sans-papiers et donc
au bout du compte comment ce texte
est-il voté parce que hélène est
majoritaire je résume enfin la droite
est majoritaire au Sénat mais j'ai pas
l'assemblée donc c'est l'impasse c'est
ce que vous nous dites le prix dans la
République hier soir chez nos confrère
de TF1 et France 2 il était attendu sur
cette question après les discours du
Pape François à Marseille réaction du
président de la République nous Français
nous faisons notre part on ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde
évidemment ça nous rappelle il
paraphrase Michel Rocard l'ancien
Premier ministre de François Mitterrand
qui avait dit à peu près la même chose
mais en deux fois et dans l'autre sens
exactement si on est bien d'accord
il s'était il s'était repris dans sa
déclaration bref Yann Brossat vous allez
combattre ce texte a fait partie de vos
premiers combats de nouveau sénateurs
bien sûr que nous le combattrons mais
nous le combattrons en portant aussi un
certain nombre d'exigences un certain
nombre de propositions nous l'avons déjà
fait d'ailleurs Fabien Roussel comme
Marie-Pierre delagontrie ont signé une
tribune qui propose la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papiers parce
qu'on a aujourd'hui des secteurs entiers
de notre économie dans les secteurs en
tension ou en général à la
régularisation de l'ensemble des
travailleurs sans papiers nous
considérons que dès lors que quelqu'un
travaille il doit pouvoir accélérer
accéder au même endroit que n'importe
quel travailleur et ce serait d'ailleurs
j'y insiste une bonne nouvelle pour ces
travailleurs-là pour ces travailleurs
sans papiers parce que cela leur
permettrait de sortir de la
clandestinité mais ce serait surtout une
bonne nouvelle pour du monde du travail
parce que aujourd'hui maintenir des
travailleurs dans cette situation de
clan destinité c'est du dumping social
qui tire tous les travailleurs vers le
bas et donc il y a certains patrons qui
en profitent mais bien sûr et on dit
aujourd'hui à quelqu'un qui a des droits
accepte des conditions de travail
dégradées parce que sinon je prendrai
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de papier et qui
lui est prêt à accepter n'importe quoi
et donc on voit bien qu'on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça regardez le secteur
de la restauration on a aujourd'hui un
secteur qui repose dans des proportions
immenses sur des personnes qui n'ont pas
de papier et donc il faut sortir de
cette situation là et la régularisation
est une solution est-ce que Dominique et
choisis ça sonne il y a une hypocrisie à
ne pas vouloir effectivement régulariser
les les travailleurs sans papiers d'une
manière générale ou au moins dans les
secteurs en tension une hypocrisie de la
part de qui de la part de votre partie
qui ont fait une ligne rouge non on va
tous dans des restaurants à Paris et je
pense que si on pousse la porte de la
cuisine on verra qu'il y a beaucoup de
travailleurs sans papiers derrière un
l'immigration comme d'ailleurs on l'a
vécu à travers le texte de la réforme
des retraites on voit réapparaître le
clivage droit de gauche d'une façon très
nette moi je pense que c'est plutôt bien
parce que c'est simple la démocratie et
donc on a vu pendant toute le débat sur
la réforme des retraites et forcément on
verra le même clivage droit de gauche
s'installer dans l'hémicycle au moment
de la discussion sur ce projet de loi
sur l'immigration
pourquoi ne pas alors je dis pas que
tous les patrons le demandent mais il y
a quand même beaucoup de patrons et
notamment au Medef qui nous disent oui
il y a des secteurs où on a besoin de de
ces travailleurs sans papiers et il faut
les pourquoi ne pas les réguler revenir
sur ce point mais c'est quand même
qu'une mesure sur l'ensemble de ces
projets c'est un aspect et donc ce que
nous avons formulé des propositions
aujourd'hui la balle est dans le temps
du gouvernement le gouvernement c'est
très bien et Gérald Darmanin les
propositions qui ont été donc énoncées
par notre groupe les républicains où
nous voulons lutter fermement contre
l'immigration illégale où nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait une réforme de la
Constitution afin que les Français
puissent dire véritablement qui peut
entrer sur le sol national et que l'on
ne soit pas contraint par des
jurisprudences qui nous mèneraient à
l'impuissance et nous voulons également
faire en sorte que toute personne qui
est présente sur le sol de façon
irrégulière puisse être systématiquement
expulsé ensuite sur la question des
travailleurs sans-papiers dans les
métiers en tension nous avons été là
aussi clair parce que nous considérons
que dans notre pays même s'ils nous
rapprochons du plein emploi il y a
encore bon nombre de Françaises et de
Français qui ne travaillent pas dans
notre pays et nous préférons
effectivement que ce soit les Françaises
et les Français qui puissent accéder à
des emplois à une formation alors vous
allez me dire ce sont des emplois qui
souvent ne sont pas pourvus parce que
les Français n'en veulent pas ou en tout
cas certes mais parce que aussi nous
avons vu la valeur travail se déprécier
au fil du temps et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle pour l'heure nous sommes
véritablement opposés à cette
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier y compris dans les métiers en
tension je vous donne la parole tout de
suite sur ce thème mais d'abord on
écoute
erikioti président du parti les
républicains hier soir alors c'était
juste après l'intervention du du chef de
l'État et les propos que je citais tout
à l'heure je crois que le Président de
la République au travers cette
intervention ce soir n'a sans doute pas
pris la mesure de la gravité de la
situation et surtout la mesure des
difficultés que subissent les Français
au quotidien et qui n'a pas pris la
mesure de la gravité de la crise
migratoire qui est devant nous voilà on
est toujours dans une forme
d'immobilisme et d'impuissance du en
même temps
Claude manuré c'est un peu ce que
décrivait ma pierre de la grande trip
tout à l'heure est-ce qu'on touche pas
là les limites quand même du en même
temps macrony sur un texte comme
celui-là sur l'immigration ce qu'on peut
envoyer de messages il semble à ce point
contradictoire je pense que sur le thème
de l'immigration il vaut mieux essayer
de trouver le thème du en même temps que
le le thème du 12 dehors ou régularisant
tout le monde donc à mon avis en tout
cas dans le principe mais en même temps
de me déplaît pas si vous voulez tout à
l'heure Marie Pierre de legrandtry
disait ce texte ne sera pas voté je
suis pas d'accord avec lequel je pense
qu'il est possible il est fort possible
ce texte soit voté d'abord parce qu'il y
a besoin de de prendre des initiatives
sur l'immigration
et mais sans excurser de la partie
régularisation d'abord parce qu'il y a
un accord général y compris chez les
électeurs de gauche sur le fait que
l'immigration soit contrôlée elle ne
l'est pas aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui
même les électeurs de Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie sont sont d'accord pour dire
qu'il faut
aujourd'hui des mesures pour contrôler
les frontières pour contrôler
l'immigration et que ça ne l'est pas ni
au niveau de la France ni au niveau de
l'Europe et c'est un vrai problème même
si des parties de gauche disent non non
il y a pas de problème leurs électeurs
disent sondage le montre qu'il y a un
vrai problème le deuxième point c'est
celui des métiers en tension qui comme
tu le disais
Dominique est une petite partie du texte
mais c'est le point central c'est le
point d'échappement et sur ce point non
seulement la gauche et la droite est un
clivage entre la gauche et la droite
mais c'est aussi un clivage à
l'intérieur de la majorité sénatoriale
puisque les centristes ont une position
différente de celle de LR or le
gouvernement il a compris que comme
c'est comme les choses se passaient mal
à l'Assemblée et qu'on avait de plus en
plus de mal à faire à faire passer les
textes et c'est pour ça que le texte
passe d'abord au Sénat
au Sénat une opposition mais une
opposition avec laquelle on pouvait
discuter et cette opposition elle va
elle-même discuter en son sein donc le
problème pour moi il est très simple
est-ce que dans la majorité sénatoriale
les deux principales forces de la
majorité sénatoriale vont arriver à se
mettre d'accord et en général elles se
mettent souvent d'accord et si par
hasard il y a un accord lorsque le texte
IR de façon nationale je vois mal les
députés LR
voter différemment de ce que leurs
collègues auront adopté je vous
interrompre parce que je vais donner la
parole à Yann brossa là-dessus et on va
parler planification écologique en
dernier thème de ce débat est-ce que
vous êtes en porte-à-faux ou en décalage
avec vos électeurs sur sur cette
question vous savez je trouve qu'on
surpolitise ces questions d'immigration
et on a nouveau c'est normal mais enfin
c'est normal c'est naturel mais on en
fait des éléments de de clivage
j'aimerais qu'on regarde la réalité en
face il y a pas très longtemps je
visitais un centre d'hébergement
d'urgence là où je suis élu dans le dans
le 18e arrondissement puis je rentre
dans le centre d'hébergement d'urgence
et je vois partout des sacs à dos
deliveroo uber eats et je discute avec
avec les personnes qui étaient hébergées
là et qui avait ses sacs aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie on
est livreur chez deliveroo et chez uber
eats j'aurais dit et vous vivez en
centre d'hébergement d'urgence oui et
certains vivaient ensemble d'hébergement
d'urgence depuis des mois pourquoi parce
que dès lors qu'ils n'ont pas de papier
ils ont même pas la possibilité de
déposer une demande de logement social
et donc voyez l'hypocrisie dans laquelle
on est on se retrouve avec des secteurs
entiers qui reposent sur des personnes
qui n'ont pas de papier et qu'en réalité
on expulsera jamais et donc ça n'est pas
gérable au-delà du clivage politique
au-delà des symboles qu'on veut faire
sur ces sujets on va pas continuer comme
ça avec des gens qui vivent ensemble
d'hébergement quoi ils vont vivre toute
leur vie dans ces centres-là c'est
absurde et donc à un moment donné la
régularisation c'est un moyen de
remettre les compteurs à zéro bon allez
on vous a tous entendu sur sur ce thème
on passe à cette question de la
planification écologique c'était
l'une des annonces importantes de ce
lundi fait par le Président de la
République qui nous vante une écologie à
la française on écoute
objectif qui est le nôtre et que nous
avons débattu la pendant les les deux
heures et demie et qui était l'objet du
travail du gouvernement depuis
maintenant 14 mois c'est de bâtir une
écologie à la française qui répond à un
triple défi qui n'est pas que le nôtre
mais celui de la planète celui du
dérèglement climatique et de ses
conséquences celui d'une effondrement de
notre biodiversité et celui de ce que je
qualifié il y a un peu plus d'un an de
fin de l'abondance c'est au fond de la
rareté de nos ressources ces engagements
ont été tenus et la planification qui a
été validée aujourd'hui et le fruit de
14 mois à la fois de travaux de
concertation dans le cadre des conseils
nationaux de la refondation qui a été
largement débattue alors plusieurs
annonces du chef de l'État reprise du
contrôle du prix de nos de notre
électricité au mois d'octobre on sait
qu'il y a une sorte de bras de fer entre
l'État actionnaires et EDF pour se
mettre d'accord sur le mécanisme qui
permet de d'évaluer le prix de
l'électricité il y a ça il y a un
million de pompes à chaleur annonce
faites d'ici à la fin du par Emmanuel
Macron et puis
il l'avait déjà évoqué le chef de l'État
la création de 13 RER métropolitain avec
le déblocage de 700 millions d'euros de
l'État pour bâtir ses 13 RER
métropolitains de la Gontrie moi
j'entends ça je me dis 700 millions
d'euros pour 13 lignes finalement c'est
pas beaucoup et il va falloir que les
collectivités territoriales mettent au
pot est-ce que vous faites la même
analyse évidemment je veux dire que moi
j'ai été élu longtemps de la région
Île-de-France je suis toujours
territorialement mais j'en étais
vice-présidente
on pourrait peut-être déjà remettre à
niveau les transports en commun
existants par exemple en région
Île-de-France et même là l'état
des difficultés à le faire peut-être
pour des difficultés budgétaires et déjà
les collectivités locales
structurellement les finances mais c'est
des centaines de millions d'euros tous
les ans donc effectivement 700 millions
d'euros annoncé ce chiffre évidemment ça
fait beaucoup de zéro je veux dire que
quand un Français écoute ça et se dire
bah oui c'est beaucoup
des annonces par milliards
c'est pas sérieux c'est une blague c'est
pas c'est pas la hauteur du débat mais
c'est pas sérieux on ne fait pas 13
voilà donc
tout ça en plus bon l'écologie à la
française voilà comment on dit que
finalement on va faire quelque chose
mais on habille tout ça est fait pour
faire croire que on était écologiste
mais en réalité voilà c'est pas toujours
pas compris on est très loin de citation
de d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir à la
télévision les Français ontiment la
bagnole et moi je l'adore Yann brossa
est-ce que dire ça à la veille de de la
grand-messe de la planification
écologique c'est pas brouiller le
message quand même d'abord moi je ne
suis pas pour culpabiliser les gens qui
qui ont une voiture évidemment moi je
suis élu d'une d'une grande métropole à
Paris on a le métro mais enfin il y a
quand même des tas d'endroits où on ne
peut pas vivre des gens dès lors qu'on a
pas de voix au milieu de Français qui
ont pas d'autres choix que d'utiliser
leur voiture et en l'occurrence on
aurait tort de les montrer du doigt la
vraie question à se poser c'est comment
on fait en sorte que les alternatives à
la voiture puissent être puissent être
développées donc les RER métropolitain
c'est pas une mauvaise idée simplement
comme le disait Marie-Pierre à l'instant
ça suppose que l'État mette massivement
la main à la poche pour les pour les
développer et puis par ailleurs on est
quand même très en deçà par exemple sur
un sujet comme la rénovation énergétique
des logements qui est pourtant un sujet
absolument fondamental à la fois un
sujet écolo et un sujet de pouvoir
d'achat on le voit en ce moment avec
l'envolée des charges d'énergie par
exemple sur la rénovation énergétique du
logement social aujourd'hui l'État ne
fait rien ce sont les collectivités
locales et les bailleurs sociaux qui
financent la rénovation énergétique des
logements sociaux or les locataires de
nos logements sociaux subissent
aujourd'hui de plein fouet l'envoler des
prix de l'énergie donc là par exemple on
aurait un chantier à ouvrir et pour
l'instant le gouvernement reste très
très timide là-dessus Dominique et Saudi
ça sonne la majorité sénatoriale dit
qu'elle est consciente de l'urgence
climatique est-ce que elle vote pour
autant les textes nécessaires à lutter
contre le réchauffement
écoutez je crois que dans un certain
nombre de textes bien évidemment on a
accompagné des mesures j'ai moi-même été
récemment président de la commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique le rapporteur en
été Guillaume Gontard peut penser que on
avait des positions qui sur certaines
sujets étaient quand même assez
différente mais pour autant on a trouvé
un consensus et on a formulé 23
propositions et j'avais dans le sens de
Yann brossa pour dire qu'aujourd'hui le
compte n'y est pas et que on annonce des
objectifs qui ne sont jamais atteints et
donc si on veut véritablement sortir de
cette déclaratoire de cette incantation
il faut mettre en face vraiment une
massification et cette massification
elle passe d'abord et avant tout par
plus de moyens financiers et arrêtons de
ponctionner les collectivités
territoriales quand j'entends hier soir
le président de la République dire que
l'augmentation de la taxe foncière et le
fait des communes quand on voit que par
ailleurs on a porté atteinte de façon
importante à l'autonomie financière et
autonomie fisc des collectivités
territoriales encore une fois c'est
inadmissable inadmissible de la part du
chef de l'État donc je crois que c'est
encore faire diversion je suis désolé
ces conseils nationaux de la refondation
qui se transforment en conseil de la
planification écologique je ne suis pas
sûr que ça débouche sur des mesures qui
véritablement font prendre conscience
aux Français qui vont être accompagnés
pour faire cette révolution dans un
certain nombre de domaines que ce soit
dans le domaine des mobilités dans le
domaine du logement
si je résume manque d'ambition manque
d'accompagnement qu'est-ce que vous
récompez à ça
je pense que le mot d'écologie et la
française n'a pas été choisi par hasard
c'est une formule c'est une formule à
mon avis qui est qui avait du sens et
notamment il y avait à mon avis dans
cette formule deux messages subliminaux
le premier message
c'est que la France on a l'habitude de
se lamenter on a l'habitude de se
plaindre que les choses ne vont pas ne
vont pas assez vite et
Dominique a notamment évoqué dans le
domaine du logement
la France et la championne du monde de
la décarbonation vous regardez toutes
les statistiques toutes les études la
France à cause de ça politique notamment
à cause politique sur l'énergie
nucléaire depuis des années et la
championne du monde de la décarbonation
donc c'est quand même un sujet le
changement climatique et nous sur lequel
moi je pense qu'on peut peut-être
essayer d'avoir des propositions
constructives mais sans se lamenter et
sans dire que tout va mal donc c'était
probablement le premier message sous
luminaire le deuxième message subliminel
à mon avis il n'était pas la destination
des pensées il était à destination de
nos partenaires européens et notamment
des Allemands parce qu'il apparaît
évident aujourd'hui que la stratégie
française amateur des carbonation était
la bonne que celle des Allemands est une
pour des raisons d'électeurs il y a il y
a une décennie une plusieurs décennies
va dans le mur et que les électricité
nucléaire qui n'est pas là est remplacé
aujourd'hui par des centrales à charbon
donc ces deux sur ces deux messages moi
je pense que la France et je parle pas
de ce gouvernement je parle des
gouvernement successifs la France n'a
pas à rougir de son trajet sur le sur le
changement climatique vous disiez Yann
brossaï on va terminer avec vous que en
matière d'immigration il fallait sortir
des postures est-ce que là vous êtes
dans une posture quand vous critiquez le
chef de l'État sur les sur le la
planification on n'est pas dans une
posture d'ailleurs sur la question du
nucléaire par exemple pour ce qui
concerne les communistes il y a aucune
ambiguïté dans notre position et nous
accompagnerons tout ce qui permettra de
déployer l'énergie nucléaire et donc
notre souveraineté énergétique on peut
pas dire à la fois qu'on veut se
débarrasser des énergies fossiles et
dans le même temps ne pas développer le
nucléaire avec bien sûr les
renouvelables mais le nucléaire quand
même en tout cas pour ce qui nous
concerne nous sommes des gens
constructifs simplement je constate que
on a face à nous un gouvernement qui
bien souvent ne fait pas avancer les
choses dans le bon sens merci à tous
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat dans
sens public je voudrais remercier une
nouvelle fois toutes les équipes de
qui peut technique et qui peut
éditoriale pour tout le travail effectué
depuis plusieurs jours pour les soirées
pour la soirée spéciale hier il y en a
certains qui ont travaillé jusque très
très tard dans la nuit donc un immense
merci à tous nous aussi oui vous avez
l'habitude
non mais vraiment un grand merci à
toutes les équipes je voudrais aussi
vous donner un rendez-vous demain dans
la matinale marine ton de lier la
secrétaire nationale d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts qui sera face à Oriane Mancini
il sera 8h du matin belle soirée